(beeping)
Welcome back to your essay writing and presentation skills class, we are back again with our lecture number eight on descriptive essay.
In the previous lecture we have thoroughly discussed the different types of essays which were so common that everyone knows of them.
We first of all talked about the descriptive essay in which the one that we are going to discuss in detail today.
Then we also discussed the definition essay which calls for the definition of something or which introduces the definition of something to the audience.
Then we also discussed the compare and contrast essay in which you do the comparison that the finding out the differences between something
and then you do the contrast, finding out the similarities and the differences between two things simultaneously.
Then we also talked about the cause and effect essay in which we discussed how something happened and we also tried to find out its effects that what happened afterwards.
Then we also discussed the narrative essay which is a kind of a story telling, telling a story.
So we also discussed that in the previous lecture as well.
Then we also discussed the argumentative essay that is also known as your persuasive essay.
We also discussed the critical essay, evaluation essay, analysis essay, reflective essay and expository essay which are some kind of exposing something related to exposing something,
critically evaluating something, then presenting your examination and description of analyzing something and presenting your reflection on something.
That one we are going to discuss one by one in every lecture, every upcoming lecture.
Since from today I will give you your assignments to do and your quizzes to do.
So you are supposed to do that once we are going to keep moving with that, right?
Now today we are going to talk about the descriptive essay.
We have done it so many times before and again we are going to do it.
We keep on repeating things because I want to make sure that you understand each of them in detail and clearly.
So to begin with let us describe that what descriptive essay is.
Descriptive essay basically provides details about how something looks, feels, tastes, smells and makes one feel or sounds.
So a descriptive essay is the clear indication of or the description of that how something looks.
Like for example if you are talking about any place, any personality, anything or you are possible or you are able to do that in a very nice way.
It can also describe what something is and how something happened.
So you are actually describing something in terms of how and why something happened, what something is and how something happened
and you are also trying to describe the process of something.
The essay generally use a lot of sensory details.
As I said in the previous lectures as well, then the descriptive essay is something that calls for all your senses.
All your imagination is involved in it. Once you are describing any personality, you try to look from every angle
and you try to see that personality from every aspect.
So from starting from the physical appearance, how they look, the way they walk, the way they eat, the way they talk
and the kind of the personality they are, the kind of the interest they have, the kind of the behaviour they have with different people
and so on and so forth. So this is how you describe your favourite personality or any personality that you are targeted to explain.
Then in the same way you try to explain a place, maybe you try to explain any monument or you try to explain any shopping place
or you try to explain the location of or how some house looks like or how some building looks like.
So this is how you are going to describe them and you are going to define them.
Then there are some common examples of as we have already discussed and some more examples that we are going to see in today's lecture.
We are going to thoroughly see that how descriptive essays are and how things can be described in different ways.
So this is how we will be able to see that how to write one descriptive essay on your own.
Now pick up your pens and your copies because that is time to actually start practicing essay writing.
I want all of you to become with very good essay writers because I am putting in all my efficiency and courage and all my knowledge
to make sure that you learn everything that I have with me so that.
The way I write if there are any loopholes I can find out while I am reading your paper and you can find out while writing your peers
and my paper that one of the loopholes in your writing because always reading others writing is the possible way that is going to help you improve your own writing skills.
So as I said that writing is a productive process you are going to produce as much information as you can.
So maybe you can just quickly grab a cup of tea before I quickly move on to the next slide and refresh your mind for writing the descriptive essay.
Now in today's lecture we are going to see that how to write one as well as we are also going to check out that how to write with different techniques
and we are also going to see some common mistakes that we usually use or we really make while writing a descriptive essay
and we are definitely going to overcome them and we are going to avoid them to become a good essay writer.
Then there are some do's and don'ts that we are going to see while we will as we will move on to our actual practice session of our descriptive essay.
So how to write one I hope you have grabbed your cup of tea now so take a sip and listen to me carefully.
So a descriptive essay is a form of academic writing now remember that is kind of a formal writing that is built around a detailed description of a person.
Maybe that can be about a person maybe any favourite personality that you have that is going to talk about the personality creates
starting from his physical appearance to his character and then his eyes, nose, lips, ears, his hair
and then you know the way he walks, the way he talks, how he behaves with his parents, his family and how he behaves with society.
And let us take example of Kaidyasam that how was his behaviour towards his family and how was his behaviour towards his relatives
and then the nation and what was his aim in life and how did he do that, did he have any kind of you know medical illness
or something so this is how you are going to see every aspect of his life starting from the day he was born till the day he died.
So this is how you wrap up the whole description of a person in one essay.
Then maybe you are describing a building, any building maybe let us talk about or let us take an example of Sintaurus that is under construction in Islamabad.
Then this project started and what is it this project all about and how does the building look like now and how it will look like in your future and what will be the shopping malls like, what will be the residential like and so on and so forth.
So this is how we are going to discuss the different places.
Maybe you are going to also describe the situation maybe a car accident, maybe a situation like your visit to your sons school or maybe very happy birthday
or visit to a happy birthday of your niece maybe.
So this is how you are going to you know describe the each and every movement of why do you want to describe that in your own words.
The main purpose of descriptive essay is to describe something in a vivid and particular manner.
So this vividness or this you know vast sensory details or vast sensations being involved in your imagination and then on the piece of paper is going to be the best description of why do you want to explain that person, that place or that very thing.
So that the reader can easily picture the described object person or state in their mind.
So that just like a painting like we have practiced and we had had some sessions practice sessions in our previous lectures that how to convert the thoughts being presented in the painting on the piece of paper.
And maybe your next assignment is going to be on the same topic.
So what you are supposed to do is to you know present each and everything that you see on the piece of paper so that the reader is going to get every single information about that thing which was there that you saw.
So to make sure for example there are games like you know see and saw so there is something that you see and then you become saw.
So you have seen that and you want to tell that thing to the other so how you are going to tell that thing to the other in your own words.
So the best imagination or the best imaginary words that you can use to describe something is going to be the best art of writing the descriptive essay.
So this is how and this is that is why we are sitting here.
I am going to tell you to write down on so and so topic along with the guideline that I will tell you and you are supposed to stick to all the rules that I am going to tell you that how to write a descriptive essay.
Now there are some steps that you are supposed to follow while writing a descriptive essay.
Your step number one says that choose a subject on which you want to write and decide what or who you will describe.
So the first thing your step number one would be your selection of the topic.
So you are going to decide that what you want to write on what would be the possible thing or place or person that you can describe in your own words.
You start from the scratch and then you reach the peak to make sure that each and every detail of that person is being described.
That's you know in other words that's a kind of a dissection of something that you try to dissect it from each and every part to see that what is there and what is inside.
So you are going to provide the minute details of everything.
Don't go into the very some sometimes a common mistake is being made that we go into the irrelevant details instead of you know focusing on the very important ones.
So this is something that sometimes you know divert the attention of your reader.
So you are going to avoid that and first step that you are supposed to make is to select for the relevant topic that you can think that you can describe.
Now describing or you know selecting a topic is something that is very difficult sometimes.
So you are going to make sure that a topic that you can describe well that you can think you are capable enough of and you can describe in an easy way you are going to do that.
Then your step number two is the two and outline or a sketch listing the facts collected as text you will develop throughout your essay.
Now your step number two would be that once you have selected a topic for your essay your second step would be that you are you know going to make an outline for that.
Now how to do that you know that better we have already discussed it in our lecture number six that how you make an outline for the essay.
Now this pre writing technique of writing an outline maybe if you are taking the topic outline or you are using the sentence outline both of them they are going to help you develop a good outline for your descriptive essay.
Based on that outline or maybe to make that outline your third step would be that you would gather information for the introductory paragraph.
If necessary in case you choose to write about a certain holiday historical event building place or well-known figure.
So for example you decide to write about Alamekbal that is your per favorite percentage or maybe you decide to write about anything that is maybe you have decided to write about the one wonders in the world out of the seven
and you want to you know write them down on in and you want to want to describe that into your essay in your essay.
So you what your practice would be that you would gather some information from the relevant sources that are available and you would you know try to define or describe that very thing in in the way that has been described in the possible source.
So the thumb rule is this step number one first of all pick up the topic second thing that you are supposed to do is to make an outline all your imagination all your ideas should come on that very outline.
If you have chosen something that is already available any famous personality any famous building or any historical event you should read about that and gather as much information as you can on your pre writing page.
Make sure that you are not going to put every information that you are going to gather from internet from any book from any source as it is if you are going to do that make sure that you are going to use the MLA Harvard system.
Then during your step number three you are going to gather as much information as you can and try to make sure that the information you are gathering from internet and the library resources should be written in MLA or APS style.
So maybe the Harvard system because if you are going to break the laws of plagiarism that is going to be problematic for you.
So I hope that you are good kids and you are not going to you know copy someone else's work to make that your own work.
You are going to work hard on writing the essay and we are sure that you will write one today.
Now your step number four for writing the essay after you have selected your topic, made an outline and gathered the information from the different sources if that was required.
Then you will decide upon the main idea for each of your paragraphs.
Now your outline calls for the heading for every paragraph that is to be you know placed that is to be selected for your essay that is the main body section.
So we are not going to touch on the introduction and conclusion yet.
We are working on the main body parts where there would be a lot of ideas related to your main subject.
Maybe you have selected a personality and you want first of all you want to talk about their physical appearance.
Then you want to talk about their behavior, then you want to talk about their ambitions and so on and so forth.
So you would have different paragraphs for each category.
So this is how you are going to define and this is how you are going to take step four for writing your descriptive essay.
Your step five will lead you to the introductory sentence.
Now for writing each paragraph as we have discussed earlier in our paragraph writing skills that each paragraph contains three parts.
The first one is your introductory sentence that introduces the main idea of the whole paragraph then your second part are your supporting details
where your main idea your introduction is being supported with a lot of examples maybe sexual evidences or the information that is relevant.
Then your third part is your closing sentence which sums up the whole information of the supporting details and your topic sentence in one line.
So this is how you are going to decide that which write each of the paragraphs in the format of writing a paragraph.
So once you are done with that your step number six would be that write the introduction and conclusion.
Once you have described the main body and once you have written down the main body based on all the topics that you have selected for your essay
you are going to start writing your introduction and your conclusion.
That would be the same way you enter any exhibition and then you have an exit from that exhibition.
So this is how you are going to do that.
Your seventh step would be that you are going to do the proper proof reading for your material that you have chosen for your essay.
Now that proof reading hasn't has to do with anything to do with your first thing that is your pre-writing.
Your proof reading is something that you would do yourself maybe or prefer asking someone to proofread your material.
Maybe you ask your friends or maybe you ask your supervisor to do that for you.
The good idea of proof reading is to take a nap maybe or take some break.
Maybe you can go out have fun with your friends and again you come out to your working desk and try to pick up the paper
and see that what have you written and how are you going to analyze that.
This is the best possible way of proof reading your material.
So we have so far discussed the seventh steps.
The first thing that you will do you will thoroughly explain the topic that you have.
First of all after the selection of the topic you are going to thoroughly explain that into your outline.
That is by using the pre-writing technique.
The second thing that you are going to do is to write down the headings for the paragraph.
Gather as much information for the material as you can by surfing on internet.
Maybe going to the library if you don't know anything about the topic.
If that has something to do with any personality any place or something like that.
Then your next step would be writing down or explaining the paragraphs.
Then you would write the introduction and your conclusion and in the end you would proofread your material
to get better results.
Now let's quickly discuss your topic selection that how to actually select a topic for your descriptive essay.
Now there are various kinds of descriptive essay that you have read of others.
Maybe on internet, maybe in the books, maybe of your friends, maybe any other topics,
any other essays that you have come or you have came across.
Now the three most common ones are those that focus around describing people.
Describing places and describing buildings.
So the most common ones are focused on describing people, places and buildings.
Sometimes they also describe different objects.
But that doesn't have got that margin of describing an object rather than you know describing a place.
Any person or any building.
Now there is a list of topics your assignment is to pick up one after we are done with our descriptive essay.
You are supposed to pick up one for writing an essay.
You are supposed to make an assignment on any one of them based on the whole outline that I am telling you to write a descriptive essay.
So here are some examples of writing good topics for each category.
So what you are supposed to do is to pick up one and write down one descriptive essay.
That is going to be your first assignment of this semester.
So topics are a person I will never forget, a place I have always wanted to go.
So what your target would be you know to describe them.
The describe may be a person I will never forget you will describe that person and the reason why you will relate it to what so ever
personality traits they had so why you want to get them.
A place I have always wanted to go.
Now you are supposed to keep in mind and you are always supposed to keep in mind that you are going to stick to your topic.
Do not beat about the bush or you know go into the unnecessary details that can you know sometimes drag your attention
from the main topic so you are going to stick to them.
A person I admire, the house of my dreams, a visit to a theatre, museum, modern art gallery whatsoever you have visited.
My Remembrance Day celebration in London, my best friend or family trip to Europe, my ideal wedding.
A person who changed my life, Venus the city of eternal romance.
Now you do not know about Venus so you can also study some literature and gather information.
My favorite fiction or writer or poet.
So these are some this is the list of topic from which you are supposed to select one and you are supposed to submit one assignment
by the end of by the time once I will guide you how to write one descriptive essay.
Now stick to all the rules and all the things that I am telling you to how to write the descriptive essay
because they are going to help you understand and see that how you are going to do one.
Now there are some key points to consider before you are going to or once you are going to write your descriptive essay.
A descriptive essay as with any other successfully written piece needs to have a clear well balanced structure.
Now that well balanced structure has something to do with your proper introduction, your main body and then your conclusion.
So this is how you are going to see that like every other essay a descriptive essay also has a clear well balanced structure.
Normally you should start with an introduction of the object person or place you plan to describe.
So use first of all introduce them with what it is and how it looks and why are you going to indescribe them.
While introducing you should specify your relation to the person, the location of the place, the purpose of the object or anything like that.
So in introduction you are going to make sure the first while introducing them you are going to specify your relation
and why you are writing about them.
For example your visit to a museum or maybe your best friend or Venus the city of romance.
What so ever topic you are going to choose you are going to make sure that in introduction you are going to specify your relation.
Maybe you have been to Venus once and maybe alright my best friend is always your best friend so you are going to specify that.
So this is how you are going to tell your relationship or your association with the place or thing or the person that you are going to describe.
Then the next key point is in the main body you should focus on the specific qualities of the chosen subject.
Now in the main body you would talk about the different specific qualities of the chosen subject and go into details of each of the most unusual qualities in the following paragraph.
Now you would talk about their specific qualities moving on to their unusual qualities in every next paragraph that you are writing.
So starting from the general and then moving to the specific and then again going into the qualities and the unusual behavior of that person.
For instance if you choose to write about a person let's say your favorite personality you could include a paragraph about their appearance
another one about their personality traits and justification.
And the third paragraph of the main body can be about the person's hobbies, talents and interests.
So this is how your progression of ideas would go on.
As you said that essay is something that is logically that has coherence and coherence.
So your essay should be well connected as to make sure that each information is well connected to the next one.
Now another point to remember is about the conclusion now that we have already discussed your introduction in which you are going to introduce the person
and also tell about your relationship to that very thing or the person or the place in the second paragraph in your main body.
You are going to clearly define the traits of that thing or you are going to provide the specific information about that very thing.
In your conclusion paragraph that should focus on your personal feelings about the chosen subject.
So that is going to be somewhat personal justifying why it had such an influence on you that you decide to write about.
So in your conclusion you will clearly tell that this was my association or you are going to clearly mention or talk about your personal feelings
about that thing and you are going to tell that and what kind of influence that thing had on you and why you were driven to write about that very.
Choose that topic for writing and you wrote about that very thing.
So this is how you are going to keep all these three points in mind of introduction of maintaining the main body and the conclusion in your mind
while you are writing a descriptive essay.
Now let's move on to the next ones.
A descriptive essay focuses on details so make sure to be specific in your descriptions.
So you are going to specify all the details clearly.
Include as many colorful adjectives as you can is always good idea.
Once you are describing things so adjectives, the use of adjectives, the colorful adjectives, the ones which are going to give colors to your essay
is going to be a good idea.
Now that doesn't mean that your essay will become colorful or you are going to write your adjectives with colors.
That doesn't mean that.
It means that the elaboration of your verbs along with the adjectives should be in a way that the verb itself looks good once it is combined with an adjective.
Another tip is to introduce some unusual facts, situations and words that you associate with person, place or object you are describing.
So try to use some unusual facts and descriptions about the person, place or thing that you are describing.
That's going to make that very person, place or thing different from others.
The more innovative and unique you get, the better. So the more innovative and the more good and unique you are in writing your essay, the better that would be because in this possible way only your essay would look different.
You would look different and your writing style would automatically look different.
So there were some key points to remember that in writing the introduction, the main points and then the conclusion that you are supposed to stick to the specific details.
Then try to also add in some unusual details that differentiate your person, your personality, your thing or your place from other persons, other things and other places.
Then also use the colorful adjectives, the use of those adjectives that make your verb special.
Then this is all about writing a unique piece of paper. So you are going to involve all your sensory details and all your imagination as much as you can.
So the best tip for this is the jot as much information down on your outline page because your outline is going to give you a best skeleton for whatsoever you are going to produce in your final draft.
Now there are also some key points to remember also. Now when going into the details of your description, group similar and opposing qualities together to make your writing sound more versatile.
Now similarities and the differences should be given together as to make your writing different from others and versatile look different.
For similar qualities use also as well as in addition to in connection to and other so many words and phrases that you can use.
For opposite qualities use at the same time in spite of this nevertheless although and however like these are those conjunctions which can be used to tie up your similarities and opposing ideas together in one essay.
So that was all about the key points that are supposed to be kept in mind while writing the descriptive essay.
Now there are some do's and some don'ts that you are supposed to do while writing an essay. So we will begin with some do's and then we will move on to some don'ts.
And you are going to stick to me and you are going to listen carefully because we are here to see that how you can make your descriptive essay look better.
To begin with we will first talk about do's. So the first thing that you are supposed to remember is the first do that you are supposed to do is that do use a variety of connective words.
Now these connective words will help you connect your logical thoughts together in one paragraph and then from one paragraph progression to the next paragraph and then so on and so forth.
So your ideas will be connected in these a variety of connective words like as we have described in the previous slide as well that these kind of words which are going to highlight the similarities as well as they are going to highlight the opposing differences
is going to be the best practice while you are writing a descriptive essay. So your descriptions would look more logical and connective your ideas would be well connected.
Do use comparisons to make your descriptions more vivid and brighter. So your description will become bright if you are going to put in or if you are going to insert in some kind of comparisons.
For example when describing an object say what it shapes reminds of you. So for example if you are talking about the long channel or maybe a long path what reminds that you of think.
See so this is how you are going to see that if you have chosen any topic for your essay writing for your descriptive essay you are going to compare that very thing your thing with the things that the possible things that they resemble with.
So you are going to insert all those comparisons here. When talking about a person compare their characteristics with that of an animal.
Maybe you tell that she the character of so and so the so and so character in Shakespeare's novel was so pretty that she resembles a moon.
So this is how like an animal flower or whatever you associate the personal quality with. So this is how you are going to see that how while associating the attributes of the personifications of for the human beings like using the enemy names of the animals or maybe you associate their qualities with that of the flowers and so on and so forth.
So this is how you can you know best compare and best describe your things more places and people.
Now the next thing that you are supposed to do is do use your emotions and analyze it how you feel about the described person place or object.
So now you are going to personally on the personal level you are going to describe your emotions about something about some person about some place and about some object do not be afraid to include your subjective opinion.
Now that is wholly solely your personal opinion that you are going to add in your essay. So you are not going to get afraid with that because that essay is your property and that was all based on what so ever you think about that place that person or that object.
Now be creative in your descriptions you were already very creative in the thing that you are supposed to do is to be creative in your descriptions.
Now another thing that you are supposed to do is that do not be afraid to approach your description from an innovative angle.
Now that you are creative yet you are innovative so you are going to provide those details as well which you think that others cannot and they are provided in such a way that you have used such words which are understandable by the common group of people but yet they are so attractive that people want to read it again and again.
Do use a variety of techniques to express your thoughts. Now you are using the variety of techniques to express your thoughts, express your emotions, express your feelings about that very thing person or place because you can only in this way you can make your piece of writing look different, feel different, think different and is going to be different from all the rest of the other pieces of writing.
So use as many colors in your descriptive essay as you can do use your innovative techniques, do use the vivid and brighter images, also use the best possible strokes of words that are coming out of your hand and put them on the piece of paper as to make a best possible essay.
So in this way only you can write a very good essay so there were some do's that you are supposed to do along with that there are some don'ts that you are not supposed to do while writing a descriptive essay.
Remember we are talking about the descriptive essay and all the do's that you are supposed to do are you are supposed to keep in mind and all the don'ts that you are not supposed to do just forget about them and stick to the rules, stick to all the processes
that we are supposed to do and essay writing is not a very hard job to do, all you need to do is to you know get a structure for that and then get that structure filled with colors, vivid images, bright injectives and everything.
Now the first don't that you are not supposed to do is don't begin all your sentences in a similar way, like you are not going to make the one sequence of the sentences or you are not going to begin all the sentences in the same way because that is going to make your writing monotonous and boring and something you know alike.
So sometimes reader will get bored while you know reading your paper they will say that this writer defines each and everything in the same way.
Now there are some novel writers who write their novels each one of their novel is written in the same way.
So once you pick up their novel or you are you know you get a hold of any extract from somewhere which does not carry their name if you read that you would automatically understand that this
extract has been taken from so and so novel of so and so person.
So don't be that type you are going to be different look different feel different and write different.
So this is what our target is that you are going to not be like other people you are going to look different and this is how this is the only possible way how your writing can look different from others.
Now don't write too generally go underneath the surface in your descriptions to make your essay sound more realistic.
Now this is the only possible way that you are going to you know go dig down the earth explore what is in there.
Now on the general level if you are talking about any personality that he was very good he was very his behavior with everyone was very good he went to school in this this year and so on and so forth.
Because these kind of the general details which everyone talks about you are not going to write them you are going to be different and you are going to add those underneath or the under surface details of that very thing in your essay as to make your essay different and look different from the others.
Don't switch from present tense to the past and then back stick if you are writing in the present tense stick to that if you are writing in the past tense stick to that you are not going to you know jump up or this switching or this swapping of two sentences in one essay is not allowed.
So you are not going to do that okay if you choose to describe it even that occurred in the past your visit to some place a person you used to be close with etc.
Then only write in the past tense throughout the essay you are not going to add any present tense in your essay if your purpose is to write about something that has happened in the past so you would talk about that thing in the past tense.
Similarly if you choose to describe everything in the present or future form be consistent throughout so I hope that you have absorbed this try to digest that if you are writing about something that has happened in the past you are going to be a stick to the past tense throughout your essay.
If you are talking about the future stick to future tense continuously and be consistent in that and if you are writing about the present tense any present event any present place so try to you know stick to the present tense throughout your essay.
But you are not going to switch up present with future or future with present or present with past or past with future and so on and so forth so you are good people and I hope you are following my directions.
Don't write about everything you can think of now while writing in essay you can think of you know 100 ideas that come in your mind but the thing that you are supposed to keep in mind is that you are not going to write about everything that you can think of.
Whether it is a person or building that you choose to describe think of the most peculiar and interesting characteristics now you are supposed to keep in mind that you are going to take out those interesting things from the person the place or the thing that is going to make that very thing look different from others.
That distinguish in highlights this particular person or distinguish that very person from other places that place from other places that thing from other things or that person from the other person.
So that was another thing that you are supposed to know that you are not going to write everything that you know of that person only those things which you think that this thing distinguishes or make that very person special from other people.
Don't focus on what is generally known believed or considered about the subject so the journal perceptions about something some person or some place are not acceptable you are not going to talk about them in your essay.
Write about your personal point of view write about your personal opinion do not stick to what people have to say stick to what you have to think.
So this is the thumb rule you are going to think about what you have to think you are not going to listen to the different people write about think that matter to you personally.
So the things that you like about that person that thing that place you are going to write about them you are not going to write about those things which other people think about that person which other people think about that place or which other people think about that thing.
So you are your personal thought in descriptive essay is very important you are going to write about your personal experiences your personal opinion about that thing and your personal description of something.
So only in this possible way you can create your own descriptive essay.
Now there are some common mistakes that everyone makes absence of the main idea the first thing is that the main idea is present now you know a lot about that thing that person or that place and you keep on writing writing writing.
But your main idea is being lost and how your essay should focus around one main idea that needs to be transparent now if you wanted to you know talk about the personality as a whole about something you are going to stick to that if you want to talk about the specification or the qualities of something your focus should be that.
So main idea should remain there students often forget about this rule and get lost in separate striking description descriptions.
Now the thing or the problem with writing descriptive essay is that the students they usually confuse description with you know unnecessary striking descriptions.
Now sometimes if you are asked to write about your best friend you would talk about your best friend and his family and then again your best friend's family father and their relatives and so on and so forth.
Now you would talk about your best friend not his family now your target or your main objective was being lost. So what you are supposed to keep in mind is that you are supposed to describe everything but that should be related to your best friend.
So this is how you make your essay clear and you present the main idea in different ways which make the whole essay sound abrupt and inconsistent. So these kind of common mistakes if you lose that very vigor of the main idea that will make your essay inconsistent and your ideas will look abrupt.
The next point of or the next common mistake that we make while writing the descriptive essay that use of too many ordinary in petty adjectives.
Now you go into the so much mind if I ask you to write about let's say the table you go into the four legs of the table and then the wood being used in the table and so much petty details that the main purpose of using the table is being lost.
So this is how your writing would everyone would do that and everyone would be using that this is a very good table this is a very smart table you can even sit on this table and stuff like that this is going to make your essay look monotonous and maybe majority of people are writing like this and this is going to be look like a mediocre essay.
So you are going to make your essay special and you are going to avoid these kind of details in your descriptive essay.
Now instead of you know using the ordinary in petty adjective try to describe the object or person from the personal perspective.
So the basic thing that you are supposed to keep in mind while writing descriptive essay is that you are going to look at that person or you are going to describe that object or that person from personal point of view.
So using your emotions and your feelings which are more important while you are writing the descriptive essay because descriptive essay calls for your sensations and your sensory details about that very thing about that person about about that object clear.
So these are the common mistakes that we make.
Next one is applying an out and out approach when you include negative adjective in your description. Now you are bringing out all the information that you have within because you are not you know you are critically describing it you are describing the positive aspect
as well as you are describing the negative aspects so you are going to stick to that. Try to use mild language in such cases for example you can replace John is arrogant with John can sometimes be rather arrogant.
So you are going to be mild and you are going to you know use the out and out approach in your essays so that there were some these were some common mistakes that we use while writing descriptive essay that you are going to avoid.
So far we have discussed different steps of writing the descriptive essay then we have also seen some of the topics that you can select for your first assignment and then we have also talked about some do's and don'ts that we are supposed to do while writing your essay
and you are not supposed to do while writing your descriptive essay and we have also talked about some common mistakes that we can make and we are yet to you know avoid them while writing the descriptive essay.
Now before you actually start working on your assignment number one your there is here is an example of a descriptive essay format on which you can you know write your descriptive essay on I brought one example and you are supposed to make your essay look different
the way this essay looks different this is the description of the restaurant and now we will see that how what kind of the vivid images or what kind of the bright injectives and the colorful words the writer uses to describe this restaurant and helps the reader make it look different from the other restaurants.
Now let's move on to the next slide. Now let's read all the paragraphs one by one that how the writer actually describes his favorite restaurant in this descriptive essay.
Now remember that in your essay writing there are no paragraphs there are no headings I have written these headings for your convenience as you can see very well on the top of the slide there is a heading of introduction paragraph.
You are not supposed to insert headings in your in your essays because essays are is a kind of a longer description and you are not to you know put headings and then some headings of everything. This is what your convenience that I have written on the slide but make sure that you are not going to do that do one.
Now this is the description of the person's favorite restaurant now let's see how he introduces that very restaurant in his introductory paragraph.
Let's read all the lines one by one and let's try to understand them and let's try to catch all the vivid images that we find.
As a child I wasn't fond of eating out my family would eat out at least once a week often more than once in every time we went anywhere but for a little place called Rivini it was a challenge for my parents.
Now see this injective little place that the writer has used Rivini was that lucky exception. Now see the description of the place that he is making that place look different from the others.
I love the place and this made my parents love it too. Now there is some special association of the writer with the place that he is you know trying to tell through words.
Now let's try to read the whole four lines again in one go and let's see that how beautifully the writer explains them or describes them.
As a child I wasn't fond of eating out my family would eat out at least once a week often more than once in every time we went anywhere but for a little place called Rivini's it was a challenge for my parents.
Rivini was that lucky exception. I love the place and this made my parents love it too. The place seems so magical and fascinating to me then.
Now the words magical and fascinating when I was still in elementary school care and surprisingly the place still very much fascinates me today.
So see the description of that how during his childhood when he was elementary school kid you know that place looked to him or seemed to him magical and fascinating and still that place was fascinating.
Now see the repetition of the words that he is using and how smartly he is using to make other people understand it too.
Just recently when I visited my old family house for Thanksgiving I was surprised and pleased now see two words surprised as well as pleased to find out the place still operated and in fact was still run by the same family.
Apart from the house in which I grew up Rivini is probably the dearest place to me in the little town and now see the description of the little town just outside of San Roman.
Where I was born and raised what is so special about the place but it is well it is hard to answer this question in just few words.
Now see the writer has written it in a such a beautiful way this last line that well it is hard to answer this question enough suggest a few words because a lot of description is required to explain that place.
That small restaurant that magical or fascinating place that little place with which he was always fascinated and he has always loved and that made his parents love that place too because for parents their kids are special and whatsoever their kids like the parents start liking that thing too.
So this is how he has introduced that place in his first paragraph that was his introduction paragraph and see how smartly he convinces and grabs the attention of the reader to make them learn more about what he has to say in the next paragraph by telling that how that place looks to him was difficult for him to explain in a few words.
So that would require a lot of words to explain that place and this is what he is going to do now.
Now he is providing supporting details number one supporting details that is the first paragraph of the supporting details.
First of all now see that he has started his paragraph with this phrase first of all now it means that he there are yet to so many second and third and fourth of all the paragraphs that he is going to explain further.
Raven is a small and cozy place now small as well as cozy and this is what probably earned my love in the first place. So the thing that was small and cozy that you know grabbed his attention and that earned his love.
This and the people who worked and still work there of course unlike the bigger now the place as well as the people who work there both of them he was in love with.
Unlike the bigger restaurants dinners and chain booflets are my parents also took me to.
Riveni was my family owned business run by Riveni was a family owned business run by a middle aged group couple Janet and Derek.
When I think about them now I still remember their warm smiles and sincere care for everyone around them.
Now see the description of those two people Janet and Derek their warm smiles and their sincere care for everyone.
Mrs. Mrs. Jan as I would call her loved orange shades now both in her outfits and in the restaurant's interior decor.
So see the description of the person how he is describing that person Mrs. Jan warm orange and yellow pomegranate furniture sunny colored napkins and curtains.
Now this is the description of the place country style hard wooden tables and stools at the bar everything was solid and comfortable about the place.
Now see the description of the place how beautifully the writer describes each and every minute detail of the place but he does not you know lose the point of that he is talking about his favorite restaurant.
Mrs. Jan would always have something orange in her outfit to match the place as I then thought. So Mrs. Jan see the description of the people and then the association of the people with the place and then you know how he remembers them how he remembers all the minute details about the people
which he have met in his childhood. Be it a bright orange ribbon in her hair or a peachy neat cotton dress or creamy red nail polish.
This women always belong to the place like nobody else and I doubt it was only the external resemblance.
So this is how he is somewhat doubtful about Mrs. Jan but yet he is you know describing her behavior towards her association with the environment or her association with the place in such a smart way that makes her look different or sound different from the others.
Now let's go into the details of the second paragraphs where the again he talks about something and some people related to that place.
Her husband who's husband now this paragraph is moving in connection to the previous paragraph so that's why he has used the pronoun and now this way of using the pronoun in the beginning of the next paragraph while you are describing something brings a special connection
or a logical progression from one paragraph to the other easily.
Her husband Mr. Derek was older with graying here in a little moustache which made him look like little strict to me at that time.
But the movement he started talking his deep soft and half-lofting voice with that particular tender frog in the throat wife.
He would make me listen to his every word with my mouth open.
Now see the description of Mr. Derek how smartly the writer is presenting Mr. Derek in front of us that he looked strict but once he started talking everyone would start laughing.
The way a man was like a magician to me everything there was magical, fascinating and even the man also looked mysterious and a magician to him.
Mysterious and a little scary even yet so fascinating and magnetic.
So everything has got that magnetic quality that is you know attaching the reader as well as the way the writer is writing we start getting into the situation as if we are directly meeting people.
And as if we are looking at the place ourselves.
And of course there was his daughter the first love of mine then a five-year-old.
She was a blonde pony, a tailed girl of seven or eight with cute bangs very lively and active.
She would be running around the place attracting the attention of the visitors with her echoing laughter.
Now that made you laugh in return or at least smile back at the little sunny creature running around the place.
See the beautiful objectives how the writer has used him in his essay and how he has you know tried to describe the person Derek and then his daughter who was the writer's first love.
So beautifully and you know that make us love this girl too and that person also looks like a magician to me at least.
Now that is that was a very short paragraph of the two supporting details that he had been providing.
Now let's quickly read the conclusion.
When I visited Rivani after all these years now the conclusion again talks about that is related to your introduction where he told that he went to his hometown for a thanks given after so long.
Now after these two these years the memories flashed back through my mind in a heartbeat and suddenly I felt like a child again.
Now see the association of the person with the place that every single description of that place appealed to him so much that he thought that he was the kid again because everything looked like the same as he returned there.
The place was still a sunny planet of orange and light very bright yet comfortably relaxing with fresh energy.
Now see the colors now I know that the place looked like orange that was a small planet.
Maybe that was a round place with wooden floor and huge windows where light was coming from every angle and that was bright and lively and you know it provides you with the spark of fresh energy.
I instantly felt like home and a big bouquet of freshly cut white daisies neatly tied with the orange ribbon made me think of Mrs. Chan.
So this is how he's explaining the or he has got that association of orange ribbon with Mrs. Jan.
The food taste in the same crispy and puffy homemade corn bread was my favorite part of the meal then and it tasted like it did in my childhood to me now.
My parents still eat at the river knee from time to time still order their favorite specials and enjoy the evening with Mrs. Jan and Mr. Derek remembering the good old times.
So this is how the writer ends up his essay here concluding that that place is still special to him as well as his parents because the parents love him as well as the place that he loved to.
So this is how he has explained and tried to you know reread that again when you get time.
You will get to know that how beautifully and how smartly the writer has used these objectives the vivid and bright images throughout the essay to make that very simple restaurant and a very small place look different from the others.
So this is your description towards things that counts and this is your the way you describe things that count towards you are writing anything about anything any place or any object.
Now I hope that you are going to write your assignments in such a way that you are going to you know provide the extraordinary details of everything that is there and you want to you know present that on the piece of paper.
So that was or that brings to end to our lecture in today's lecture we have talked about that how to write a descriptive essay.
We have thoroughly discussed that what is a descriptive essay.
So a descriptive essay usually tries to describe something from the personal point of view of the author.
There are three major areas in which you can you know write descriptive essay the first one is people the any personality that you want to talk about a person.
Second thing that you can write about is a place and third thing that you can write about is a thing.
So we have also discussed some of the steps for writing a descriptive essay in which we have seen that how you can after selecting your topic write down your introduction.
Then write down your main body parts and then write down your closing sentence or your conclusion for the whole essay.
Then we have also seen some of the topics for descriptive essay out of which we are you are supposed to pick up one and submit your assignments on.
Then key points to consider a few things that we have read and you know you are supposed to keep in mind while writing the descriptive essay.
Then there are some dos and then there are some don'ts that you are supposed to do and you are not supposed to do.
Everything you do or everything you don't do lead you to write a very good descriptive essay.
Don't put in the common mistakes that everyone does because you are here to you know make yourself look special and sound special from other people.
So this is the only possible way that how you can you know enhance your writing skills and how you can use your imagination and what is within you for providing the best possible details of a descriptive essay.
Then we have also seen one example of the my favourite restaurant which the writer so beautifully tells about his favourite place that was Riveny, that small orange planet where that was fascinating, magical and magnetic to him in the childhood.
And still that place was and sounded look different and you know that place attracted him once he grew up.
Now the way the writer has described his favourite restaurant I want you to describe your topics out of the topics that out of the list that I have given you and describe that in a very different way using all your imagination, bright colours, you know strong strokes, bold strokes and bold your essay should be bold enough to present to be presented on hard canvas.
So I wish you good luck for your essay writing assignment till then till the next lecture I wish you a very good luck for your assignment number one.
I hope you are going to put your steps down and roll up your sleeves, pick up your pen and your writing pad and you are going to start writing about your essay.
Start writing, I am say to you goodbye, I will see you in the next lecture with your assignment number one and we will meet again in Shala.
In the next lecture we will again discuss another essay type in detail along with the example.
I hope today's lecture was fun for you and I enjoyed it too.
Hope to see you in the next class till then take very good care of yourself and take your sip of your coffee that is getting cold.
I will see you in the next lecture and I will see you in the next lecture.